[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to the ai
alignment podcast series i'm lucas perry
and today we will be speaking with peter
singer about his transition from being a
moral anti-realist to a moral realist
in terms of ai safety and alignment this
episode primarily focuses on issues and
moral philosophy
in general i found the space of moral
philosophy to be
rather neglected in discussions of ai
alignment where persons are usually only
talking about strategy and technical
alignment
if it is unclear at this point moral
philosophy and issues and ethics make up
a substantial part of the ai alignment
problem and have implications in both
strategy and technical thinking
in terms of technical ai alignment it
has implications in preference
aggregation and its methodology
in inverse reinforcement learning and
preference learning techniques in
general
it affects how we ought to proceed with
inter-theoretic comparisons of value
with idealizing persons or agents in
general and what it means to become
realized
how we deal with moral uncertainty and
how robust preference learning vs moral
reasoning systems should be
in ai systems it has very obvious
implications in determining the sort of
society we are hoping for
right before during and right after the
creation of agi
in terms of strategy strategy has to be
directed at some end and
all strategies smuggle in some sort of
values or ethics and it's just good here
to be mindful of what those exactly are
and with regards to coordination we need
to be clear
on a descriptive account of different
cultures or groups
values or meta-ethics and understand how
to move from the state of all current
preferences and ethics onwards given our
current meta-ethical views and credences
all in all this barely scratches the
surface but it's just a point to
illustrate the interdependence going on
here
hopefully this episode does a little to
nudge your
moral intuitions around a little bit and
impacts how you think about
the ai alignment problem in coming
episodes i'm hoping to pivot into more
strategy and technical interviews
so if you have any requests ideas or
persons you would like to see
interviewed
feel free to reach out to me at lucas
futureoflife.org
as usual if you find this podcast
interesting or useful
it's really a big help if you can help
share it on social media
or follow us on your preferred listening
platform as many of you will already
know
peter is a world-renowned moral
philosopher known for his work on animal
ethics
utilitarianism global poverty and
altruism
he is a leading bioethicist the founder
of the life you can save
and currently holds positions at both
princeton university
and the university of melbourne and so
without further ado
i give you peter singer
thanks so much for coming on the podcast
peter it's really wonderful to have you
here
oh it's good to be with you so just to
jump right into this
it would be great if you could just take
us through the evolution
of your meta ethics throughout your
career
as i understand you began giving most of
your credence
to being an anti-realist and a
preference utilitarian but then over
time it appears that you've developed
into
a hedonic utilitarian and a moral
realist
take us through the evolution of these
views and and how you've developed and
arrived at your new ones
okay well when i started studying
philosophy which was in the
1960s i think the dominant view at least
among people who
were not religious and didn't believe
that morals were somehow an objective
truth handed down by god
was what was then referred to as an
emotivist view that is the idea that our
moral judgments
express our attitudes particularly
obviously from the name of emotional
attitudes
that they're not statements of fact they
don't purport to describe anything
rather they express attitudes that we
have and they encourage others to share
those attitudes
so that was probably the first view that
i
held siding with people who were
non-religious it seemed like a fairly
obvious option
then i went to oxford and i studied with
rm
hare who's a professor of moral
philosophy at oxford at the time and a
well-known figure in the field
his view was also in this general
ballpark of non-objectivist or
as we would now say non-realist theories
non-cognitivist was another term used
for them they didn't purport to be about
knowledge
but his view was that when we make a
moral judgment we are prescribing
something so
his idea was that moral judgments fall
into the general family
of imperative judgments so if i tell you
shut the door that's an imperative it
doesn't say anything that's true or
false
and moral judgments were a particular
kind of imperative
according to hair but they had this
feature that they had to be
universalizable so by universalizable
hair meant
that if you were to make a moral
judgment
your prescription would have to hold in
all
relevantly similar circumstances and
relevantly similar was defined in such a
way
that it didn't depend on who the people
where so for example if i were to
prescribe
that you should be my slave the fact
that i'm the slave master and you're the
slave
isn't a relevantly similar circumstance
if there's somebody just like me
and somebody just like you but i happen
to occupy
your place then the person who
is just like me would also be entitled
to be the slave master
of me because now i'm in the position of
the slave
obviously if you think about moral
judgments that way
that does put a constraint on what moral
judgments you can accept because
you wouldn't want to be a slave
presumably so i like this view
better than the straightforwardly
emotivist view because it did
seem to give more scope for argument it
seemed to say
look there's some kind of constraint
that really
in practice means we have to take
everybody's interests into account
and i thought that was a good feature
about this and i drew on that in various
kinds of applied
contexts where i wanted to make moral
arguments so that was my position
i guess after i was at oxford and for
some decades
after that but i was never completely
comfortable with it
and the reason i was not completely
comfortable with it was that
there was always a question you could
ask on his view hair said you know
where does this universalizability
constraint come from on our moral
judgment
and his answer was well it's a feature
of moral language
it's implied in say using the terms
ought
or good or bad or duty or obligation
it's implied that the judgments you are
making are
universalizable in this way and that in
itself was
plausible enough but it was open to the
response that
well in that case i'm just not going to
use moral language
you know if moral language requires me
to make universalizable prescriptions
and that means that i can't do all sorts
of things i can't
advocate all sorts of things that i
would want to advocate
then i just won't use moral language to
justify my conduct i'll use some other
kind of language maybe
prudential language language of
furthering my self-interest
and what's wrong with doing that
moreover you know it's not just that
they can do that but
tell me what's wrong with them doing
that so this is a kind of a question
about
why act morally and on here's view it
wasn't
obvious from his view what the answer to
that would be
and in particular it didn't seem that
there would be any kind of answer about
that's irrational or you're missing
something
it seemed really as if it was an open
choice that you had
whether to use moral language or not so
as i got further into the problems i
tried to
develop arguments that would show that
it was a requirement of reason not just
a requirement of
moral language but a requirement of
reason that we universalize our
judgments and
yet there was obviously a problem in
fitting that in to his framework which
is
i've been saying was a framework within
this general non-cognitivist family
and for hair the idea that their
objective reasons for action
didn't really make sense there were just
these desires that we had
which led to us making prescriptions and
then
the constraint that we universalized the
prescriptions but
he explicitly talked about the
possibility of objective prescriptions
and said that that was a kind of
nonsense which i think comes out of the
general background of the kind of
philosophy that came out of logical
positivism and the verificationist idea
that things that you couldn't verify
were nonsense or so on so that's why i
was pretty uncomfortable with this but i
didn't really see great alternatives to
it for some time
and then i guess gradually i was
persuaded by
a number of philosophers who work i
respected
that hair was wrong about rejecting the
idea of objective truth and morality
i talked to tom nagle and probably most
significant was the work of derek
parfait
and especially his work on what matters
volumes one and two
which i saw in advance in draft form he
circulated
drafts of his books to lots of people
who he thought might give him some
useful criticism
and so i saw that many years before it
came out and
the arguments did seem to me pretty
strong particularly the objections to
the kind of view
that i had held which by this time was
no longer usually called emotivism but
was called expressivism but i think it's
basically
a similar view of you in the same
ballpark and so i
came to the conclusion that there is a
reasonable case for saying that they're
objective moral
truths and this is not just a matter of
our attitudes or of our
preferences universalised but there's
something stronger going on
and it's in some ways more like the
objectivity of
mathematical truth or perhaps of logical
truths
it's not an empirical thing this is not
something you can
describe you know that comes in the
world a natural world of our senses that
you can
find or prove empirically it's rather
something that is rationally
self-evident i guess to people who
reflect on it properly and think about
it carefully
so that's how i gradually made the move
towards
objectivist matter i think i think here
it would be really helpful if you could
thoroughly unpack what your hedonistic
utilitarian objectivist
metaethics actually looks like today
specifically getting into the most
compelling arguments that you found in
parfit
and in nagel that led you to this view
first though i think we should be clear
that being an objectivist
about meta ethics is one thing being a
hedonist
rather than a preference utilitarian is
a different thing and i'll describe
and there's some connection between them
as i'll describe in a moment but i could
have easily become an objectivist and
remained a preference utilitarian or
held some other kind of normative moral
view
so the meta ethic view is separate from
that
why did i what were the most compelling
arguments here
i think one of the things that it stuck
with me for a long time and that had
restrained me from moving in this
direction
was the idea that it's hard to know what
you mean when you say that something is
an objective truth
outside the natural world so in terms of
saying that things are objectively true
in science the truth of scientific
investigation we can say well
there's all of this evidence for it no
rational person would
refuse to believe this once they were
acquainted with all of this evidence
so that's why we can say that that is
objectively true
but that's clearly not going to work for
truths and ethics which
assuming of course that we we're not
naturalists that we don't think this can
be deduced from some
examination of human nature or the world
i certainly don't think that and
as i say the people who are in french
army nagel and parfait in particular
also didn't think that so then the
restraining question was sort of well
what could this really command to
i'd known going back to um the
intuitionists in the early 20th century
people like w d ross or earlier uh
henry sidrick who's a utilitarian
objective
philosopher that people made the
parallel with
mathematical truths that they're a
mathematical truths that we
see as true by insight by direct insight
into their truth by their self-evidence
but i had i've been concerned about this
i've never really done a deep study of
philosophy of mathematics but i've been
concerned about this
because i thought there's a case for
saying that mathematical truths
are really analytic trees they're trues
in virtue of the meanings of the terms
in virtue of the way we define what we
mean by the numbers and by
equals or the various other terms that
we use in mathematics so that it's
basically just
the unpacking of an analytic system a
lot of
philosophers that i respected didn't
think this you had perhaps had been
more popular at the time when i was a
student and that stuck with me for a
while
and although it's not disappeared i
think it's perhaps not as
widely held a view now as it was then
so that plus the arguments that were
being made about how do we understand
mathematical truth how do we understand
the truths of logical inference
we grasp these as self-evident we find
them undeniable
yet this is again a truth that is not
part of the empirical world
but it doesn't just seem that it's an
analytic truth either it doesn't just
seem that it's the meanings of the terms
it does seem that we know something when
we know the truths of logic or the
truths of mathematics
on this basis it started to seem like
the idea that there are these
non-empirical truths of in ethics as
well
might be more plausible than i'd thought
it was before
and i also went back and read henry
sidrick who is a philosopher that i
greatly admire and that powerful
also greatly admired and looked at his
arguments about what he saw
as what he called moral axioms and
that's obviously makes the parallel with
axioms of
mathematics i looked at them and they
did seem to me
difficult to deny that is claims for
example
that there's no reason for preferring
one moment of our existence to another
in itself in other words we shouldn't
discount the future
except for things like uncertainty but
otherwise the future is
just as important as the present an idea
somewhat similar to here's
universalizability but somewhat
differently stated by
cedric that if something is right for
some
one then it's right independently of the
identities of the people involved
but for cedric as i say that was again a
truth of reason
not simply an implication of the use of
particular moral terms
thinking about that that started to seem
right to me too
and i guess finally citrix claim that
the interests of
one individual are no more important
than the interests of another
assuming that the goods involved that
can be done to the that person that is
the extent of their interests
are similar cedric's claim was that
people reflecting carefully on these
truths can see that they're true and
i thought about that and it seemed to me
that it was pretty difficult to deny not
that
nobody will deny them but that they do
have a
kind of self-evidence about them that
seemed to me to be a better basis for
ethics than
the views that i've been holding up to
that point the views that i say came out
of originally emotivism and then out of
prescriptivism
there was a reasonable chance that that
was right as you say i should give it
more credence than i had it's not that
i'm 100
certain that it's right by any means but
that's a plausible view that's worth
defending and trying to see what
objections people make to it i think
there's like three things here that
would be
helpful for us to dive in more on
the first thing is and this isn't a part
of meta ethics which i am particularly
acquainted with so potentially you can
help guide us through this part a little
bit more
this non-naturalism versus naturalism
argument
your view is i believe you're claiming
as a non-naturalist view as you're
claiming that you cannot
deduce the axioms of ethics or the basis
of ethics
from a descriptive or empirical account
of the universe
that's right there certainly are still
naturalists around i guess peter
ralphton is a
well-known contemporary philosophical
naturalist
perhaps frank jackson my australian
friend and colleague
and some of the naturalist views have
become more complicated than they used
to be
i suppose the original idea of
naturalism that people might be more
familiar
with is simply the claim that there is a
human nature
and that acting in accordance with that
human nature is the right thing to do
so you describe human nature and then
you
draw from that what are the
characteristics that we ought to follow
that i think just simply doesn't work i
think it has its origins in a religious
framework
in which you think that god has created
our nature with
particular purposes that we should
behave in certain ways
but the naturalists who defend it going
back to aquinas even
maintain that it's actually independent
of that view
if you in fact you take an evolutionary
view of human nature as i think we
should
then our nature is morally neutral you
can't derive any moral conclusions from
what our nature is like it might be
relevant to know what our nature is like
in order to
know you know that if you do one thing
that might lead to certain consequences
but it's quite possible that for example
our nature is to
seek power and to use force to obtain
power that that's an element of human
nature or at a group level to go to war
in order to have power over others
and yet no naturalists wouldn't want to
say that those are the right things
they would try and give summer candice
to white house somehow that's a
corruption of human nature
putting aside like naturalist accounts
that involve human nature
what about like a purely descriptive or
empirical understanding of the world
which includes for example sentient
beings
and suffering and suffering is like a
substantial and real
ontological fact of the universe and the
potential of
deducing ethics from facts about
suffering and what it is like to suffer
would that not be a form of naturalism i
think you have to be very careful about
how you formulate
this what you said sounds a little bit
like what sam harris says in his book
the moral landscape
which does seem to be a kind of
naturalism because he thinks that
you can derive moral conclusions from
science including exactly the kinds of
things
that you talked about but i think
there's a gap there
and the gap has to be acknowledged
you can certainly describe suffering and
you can describe happiness conversely
but you need to get beyond description
if you're going to have a normative
judgment that is you're going to have a
judgment that
says what we ought to do or what's the
right thing to do or what's a good thing
to do
there's a step that's just being left
out if
somebody says sentient beings can suffer
pain
or they can be happy this is what
suffering pain is like this is what
being happy is like
therefore we ought to promote happiness
which goes back to david hume who
pointed this out that
various moral arguments describe the
world using
is is is this is the case and then
suddenly but without any explanation
they say and therefore we ought needs to
be explained how you get from the is
statements to the or statements
it seems that reason whatever reason
might be and however you might
define that seems to do a lot of work at
the foundation of your moral view
because
it seems that reason is what leads to
you
towards the self-evident truth of
certain
foundational ethical axioms why might we
not be able to pull the same sort of
move
with a form of naturalistic moral
realism like sam harris develops by
simply stating that given a full
descriptive account of the universe
and given first-person accounts of
suffering and what suffering is like
that it is self-evidently true
that built into the nature of that sort
of property or part of the universe is
that it ought to be
diminished well if you're saying that i
mean there is kind of a fine line maybe
this is what you're suggesting between
saying from the description we can
deduce what we ought to do
and between saying when we reflect on
what suffering
is and when we reflect on what happiness
is we can see that it is self-evident
that we
ought to promote happiness and we ought
to reduce
suffering so i regard that as a
non-naturalist position
but you're right that the two come quite
close together in fact this is one of
the interesting features of volume
three of uh profits on what matters
which was only published
posthumously but was completed before he
died and in that he responds
to essays that are in a book that i
edited called does anything really
matter the original idea was that he
would respond
in that volume but as often happened
with profit he
wrote responses at such length that it
needed to be a separate volume it would
have made
the work too bulky to put him together
but peter railton had an essay
in does anything really matter and
parfait responded to it and then he
invited
railton to respond to his response and
essentially
they are saying that yeah their views
have become closer anyway there has been
a convergence which is pretty unusual in
philosophy because philosophers tend to
emphasize the differences between their
views
between what parfait calls his
non-natural objectivist view
and between railton's naturals view
because relatives is a more
sophisticated naturalist view
the line starts to become a little thin
i agree but
to me the crucial thing is that you're
not just saying here's this description
therefore we ought to do this but you're
saying if we understand
what we're talking about here we can
have as an intuition of self-evidence
the proposition that it's good to
promote this or it's good to try to
prevent this so that's the moral
proposition that it is good to do this
and that's the proposition
that you have to say you have to take
some other step you know you can say
it's self-evident but you have to take
some other steps from simply saying this
is what suffering is like
just to sort of capture and understand
your view a bit more here
and going back to i think mathematics
and
reason and what reason means to you and
how it operates at the foundation of
your ethics
i think that a lot of people will sort
of get lost
or potentially feel it is maybe
a arbitrary or cheap move to
when thinking about the foundations of
mathematics there are like foundational
axioms which are self-evidently true
which no one will deny
and then sort of translating that move
into the foundations
of ethics into determining what we ought
to do
it seems like there would be a lot of
people being lost there there'd be a lot
of foundational disagreement there like
when is it permissible or okay or
rational
to make that sort of move what does it
mean to say that
these really foundational parts of
ethics are self-evidently true
how is it not the case that that's
simply an illusion or simply a byproduct
of evolution that we're confused that
these certain fictions that we've
evolved
are self-evidently true firstly let me
say as i mentioned before i don't claim
that we can be 100 certain about moral
truths but
i do think that it's a plausible view
and one reason why it relates to
you just mentioned you know being a
product of evolution
one reason why it relates to that and
this is something that i argued with my
co-author katagina de lazari ruddock in
2014 book we wrote called the point of
view of the universe
which is in fact a phrase from from
sedgwick and that argument is
that there are a number of moral
judgments that we make
many moral judgments that we make that
we know have evolutionary origins
so lots of things that we think of as
wrong originated
because they would not have helped us to
survive or they would not have helped a
small
tribal group to survive to allow certain
kinds of conduct
and some of those we might want to
reject today
we might think for example you know we
have an instinctive repugnance of incest
but jonathan hyde has shown
that even if you describe a case adult
brothers and sisters who choose to have
sex
and nothing bad happens as a result of
that their relationship remains as
strong as ever
and they have fun and that's the end of
it people still say
oh but somehow that's wrong they try to
make up reasons why
it's wrong that i think is an example of
an evolved impulse
which perhaps is no longer really
opposite because we have effective
contraception and so you know
the evolutionary reasons why we might
want to avoid incest are not necessarily
there but in the case of the kinds of
things that
i'm talking about that citric is talking
about like the idea that everyone's
good is of equal significance
it's very hard to see why we would have
evolved to have
that attitude because in fact it seems
harmful to our prospects of survival and
reproduction
to give equal weight to the interests of
complete strangers
the fact that people do think this and
if you look at a whole lot of different
independent historical ethical
traditions
in different cultures and different
parts of the world at different times
you do find
many thinkers who converge on something
like this idea
in various formulations so
why do they converge on this given that
it doesn't seem to have that
evolutionary
justification or explanation as as to
why it would have evolved
i think that suggests that it may be a
truth of reason and
of course you may then say well but but
reason has also evolved
and indeed it has but i think that
reason may be a little different in that
we evolved the capacity to reason very
specific problem-solving
needs helped us to survive in lots of
circumstances
but it may then enable us to see things
that have no survival value
just as no doubt simple arithmetic has a
survival value
but understanding the truths of higher
mathematics don't really have a survival
value
so maybe similarly in ethics there are
some
of these more abstract universal truths
that don't have a survival
value but which nevertheless the best
explanation for why
many people seem to come to these views
is that they're trues of reason and once
we
capable of reasoning we're capable of
understanding these truths
let's start off at reason and reason
alone
when moving from reason and thinking i
guess alongside here
about mathematics for example how is one
moving
specifically from reason to
moral realism and what is sort of the
metaphysics
of this kind of moral realism in a
naturalistic
universe without anything supernatural i
don't think that it
needs to have a very sort of heavyweight
metaphysical
presence in in the universe parfait
actually avoided the term
realism in describing his view he said
called it non-naturalistic
normative objectivism because he thought
that realism
carried this idea that it was part of
the furniture of the universe
as philosophers say that the universe
consists of the various material objects
that are in it but in addition to that
it consists of moral truths as if
they're somehow sort of floating there
out in space
and that's not the right way to think
about it i'd say rather the right way to
think about it
is you know as fresh we do with logical
and mathematical truths
that once you have beings capable of a
certain kind of thought
they will move towards these truths they
have the
potential the capacity for thinking
along these lines
one of the claims that i would make the
consequences of my
acceptance of objectivism in ethics as
the rationally based objectivism
is that the morality that we humans have
developed on earth in this anyway at
this more abstract
universal level is something that aliens
from another galaxy
could also have achieved if they had
similar capacities of thought or maybe
greater capacities of thought
it's always a possible kind of logical
space you could say or a rational space
that is there
that beings may be able to discover once
they develop those capacities
you can see mathematics in that way too
it's at least it's one of a number of
possible ways of seeing mathematics and
of seeing logic they're just timeless
things that in some way
truths or laws if you like but they
don't exist in the sense
in which the physical universe exists
i think that's really a very helpful way
of putting it so the claim here is that
the reason one can develop the axioms of
mathematics and then
eventually develop quantum physics and
other things and similarly
when reason is applied to thinking about
what one ought to do
or when thinking about the status of
sentient creatures that
one is applying logic and reason to this
rational space
and that this rational space has truths
in the same way that mathematics does
yes that's right has at least perhaps
only a very small number
sedgwick came up with three axioms um
perhaps only a very small number of
truths and
fairly abstract truths but that they are
trues that's the important
aspect that they're not just particular
attitudes which
beings who evolved as homo sapiens
evolved are likely to
understand and accept but beings who
evolved in a different galaxy in a quite
different way
would not accept my claim is that if
they are also capable of reasoning if
evolution had again produced
rational beings they would be able to
see the truths
in the same way as we can so spaces of
rational thought
and of logic which can or cannot be
explored
seems very conceptually queer to me such
that i
don't even really know how to think
about it i think that
one would worry that one is applying
reason whatever reason might be
to a fictional space i mean you're
discussing earlier
that some people believe mathematics to
be simply
the formalization of what is
analytically true about the terms and
judgments
and the axioms and then it's just kind
of the systematization of that and an
unpacking of it from
beginning into infinity and so i guess
it's unclear to me how one
can discern spaces of rational inquiry
which are real from ones which are
anti-real or which are
fictitious does that make sense it's a
problem i'm not denying that
there is something mysterious
i think um maybe my former professor
aaron here would have said
queer no john mackey actually john
mackey was also at oxford when when i
was there
who said you know these are very must be
very queer things if there are some
objective moral truths
i'm not denying that it's something that
in a way would be much simpler if we
could explain everything in terms of
empirical examination of the natural
world and say there's only that
plus there are formal systems you know
there are analytic systems where
but i'm not persuaded that that's a
satisfactory explanation of mathematics
or logic either
so if those who are convinced that this
is a satisfactory way of explaining
logic and mathematics
may well think that then they don't need
this explanation of ethics either
but it is a matter of if we need to
appeal to something outside the
natural realm to understand some of the
other things about the way we reason
then
perhaps ethics is another candidate for
this so just drawing parallels again
here with mathematics because i think
it's the most helpful
mathematics is incredible for helping us
to describe and predict the universe
the president of the future of life
institute max tegmark
develops an idea of potential
mathematical
platonism or realism where the universe
can be understood
primarily as and sort of ontologically a
mathematical object within
potentially a multiverse because as we
look into the sort of properties and
features of
quarks and the building blocks of the
universe all we find
is more mathematical properties and
mathematical relationships
so within the philosophy of math there's
certainly it seems
open questions about what math is and
what the relation of mathematics is to
the fundamental metaphysics and ontology
of the universe and potential
multiverse so in terms of ethics what
sort of
information or insight or anything
do you think that we're missing could
further inform our view
that there potentially is objective
morality or whatever that means or
inform us that there is a space of
moral truths which can be arrived at by
non-anthropocentric minds like alien
minds you said could also arrive at the
moral truths as they could also arrive
at mathematical truths
so what further insight would show that
this was correct other presumably than
the arrival of aliens who
start swapping mathematical theorems
with us and have arrived at the same
moral views for example if they show up
and like hey we're hedonistic
consequentialists and we're really
motivated to
i'm not saying they'd necessarily be
hidden as the consequentialists but um
but they would say yeah you know
uh that's a different question right we
haven't really discussed
steps to get there yet so i think
they're separate questions
you know my idea is that they would be
able to see that if we had similar
interests to the ones that they did
then those interests sort of get similar
weight that they shouldn't ignore our
interests just because we're not members
of whatever
civilization or species they are
i would hope that if they are rationally
sophisticated they would at least be
able to see that argument right
some of them just as with us might see
the argument and then say you know
yes but i love the taste of your flesh
so much i'm going to kill you and eat
you anyway
so like us they may not be purely
rational beings we're obviously not
purely rational beings but if they can
get here and contact us somehow it
should be sufficiently rational to be
able to see
the point of the moral view that i'm
describing but you know that wasn't a
very serious suggestion about waiting
for the aliens to arrive
and i'm not sure that i can give you
much of an answer to say what further
insights
are relevant here maybe it's interesting
to try and look at this
across culturally as i was saying and to
examine the way that
great thinkers of different cultures and
different eras have converged on
something
like this idea despite the fact that it
seems unlikely to have been
directly produced by evolutionary means
in the same way that our other more
emotionally
driven moral reactions are i don't know
that the argument can go any further and
it's not completely conclusive but i
think
it remains plausible you might say well
that's a stalemate
you know here are some reasons for
thinking morality is objective and other
reasons for
rejecting that and that's possible that
happens in philosophy we get down to
sort of bedrock disagreements and it's
hard to move
people of different views what is
reason one could also view reason as as
some like
human-centric bundle of both logic
and intuitions and one can be mindful
that the intuitions which are sort of
bundled with this logic
are almost arbitrary consequences of
evolution
so what is reason fundamentally what
does it mean that other
reasonable agents could explore spaces
of
math and morality in similar ways well i
would argue that there are
common principles that don't depend on
our specific human nature and don't
depend on the path of our evolution
except to the extent that because the
path of our evolution has
given us the capacity to solve various
problems
through thought and that that is what
our reason amounts to
and therefore we have insight into these
truths
that we would not have if we did not
have that capacity
for this kind of reasoning you can think
of as something that goes beyond
specific problem-solving skills
to insights into laws of logic
laws of mathematics and laws of morality
as well
when we're talking about axiomatic parts
of mathematics
and logics and potentially ethics here
as you're claiming with this moral
realism
how is it that reason allows us to
arrive
at the correct axioms in these rational
spaces
we develop the ability when we're
presented with these things
to consider whether we can deny them or
or not
whether they are truly self-evident
we can reflect on them we can talk to
others about them we can consider
biases that we might have that might
explain
why we believe them and see whether
there are any such biases
and once we've done all that we're left
with the insight that some things we
can't deny
i guess i'm just sort of poking at this
idea of self-evidence here which is
doing a lot of work in the moral realism
i mean
whether or not something is self-evident
at least to me it seems like a feeling
like i just look at the thing and i'm
like clearly that's true and if i get a
little bit meta i ask
okay why is it that i think that this
thing is obviously true
well i don't really know it just seems
self-evidently true it just seems so
and this potentially just seems to be a
consequence of evolution and
of being imbued with whatever reason is
so i don't know if i can always trust my
intuitions about things being
self-evidently true i'm not sure how to
navigate my intuitions and views of what
is self-evident in order to come upon
what is true
as i said it's possible that we're
mistaken that i'm mistaken in these
particular instances
i can't exclude that possibility but it
seems to me the best hypothesis that
we hold these views because they are
self-evident and
looked for evolutionary explanations and
as i've said i've not really found them
so that's as far as i can go with that
just moving along here a little bit and
i'm becoming increasingly mindful of
your time
would you like to cover briefly this
sort of shift that you had
from preference utilitarianism to
hedonistic
utilitarianism so again let's go back to
my
autobiographical story for hair
the only basis for making moral
judgments was to start from our
preferences
and then to universalize them
there could be no arguments about
something else being intrinsically
good or bad you know whether it was
happiness or
whether it was justice or freedom or
whatever because that would be
to import some kind of objective claims
into this debate that just didn't have a
place in his framework so all i could do
was
take my preferences and prescribe them
universally
and as i said that involved putting
myself in the position of the others
affected by my action
and asking whether i could still accept
it when you do that
and if you let's say your action affects
many people not just you and
one other what you're really doing is
you're trying to sum up
how this would be from the point of view
of every one of these people
so if i put myself in a's position would
i be able to accept this but then i've
got to put myself in b's position as
well and c
and d and so on and to say can i accept
this
prescription universalized is to say if
i were living the lives of all of those
people
would i want this to be done or not and
that's a kind of as i say a summing of
the extent to which
doing this satisfies everyone's
preferences
net on balance after deducting of course
the way in which it
thwarts or frustrates or is contrary to
their preferences
so this seemed to be the only way in
which you could
go further with his view as he
eventually worked it out it changed a
little bit over the years but in his
later formulations of it so it was a
kind of a preference utilitarianism that
it led to
and i was reasonably happy with that and
i accepted the idea that
this meant that what we ought to be
doing is to
maximize the satisfaction of preferences
and avoid
thwarting them and it gives you in many
cases of course somewhat similar
conclusions to what you would say if
what we want to do is maximize happiness
and minimize
suffering or misery because for most
people
happiness is something that they very
much desire and misery is something that
they don't want
some people might have different
preferences that are not related to that
but
you know for most people they will
probably come down in some way or other
to
how it relates to their well-being their
interests
there are certainly objections to this
and some of the objections relate to
preferences that people have when
they're not fully informed
about things and his view was that in
fact the preferences that we should
universalize are the preferences people
should have when they are fully informed
and when they're thinking calmly they're
not let's say angry with somebody and
therefore they have a strong preference
to hit him in the face
even though this will be bad for them
and bad for him
so the preference view sort of then took
this further step of saying
it's the preferences that you would have
if you were well informed and rational
and calm and that seemed to solve some
problems with preference utilitarianism
but it gave rise to
other problems one of the problems were
well does this mean that if somebody is
is misinformed in a way that you can be
pretty confident they're never going to
be correctly informed
you should still do what they would want
if they were correctly informed
and an example of this might be someone
who has a very firm religious believer
and has been all their life and let's
say you know one of their religious
beliefs
is that having sex outside marriage is
wrong
because god has forbidden it let's say
it's contrary to the commandments or
whatever
but given that let's say let's just
assume there is no god
therefore affordiori there's no
commandments that god made against
sex outside marriage and given that if
they didn't believe in god they would be
happy to have sex outside marriage and
this would make them happier and would
make their partner happy as well
should i somehow try to angle things so
that
they do have sex outside marriage even
though as they are now they
prefer not to and that seems a bit of a
puzzle
really seems highly paternalistic to
ignore their
preferences in the base of their
knowledge even though you're convinced
that their knowledge is false
so there were there were sort of puzzles
and paradoxes like that
and then there was another argument that
does actually again come out of cidric
although i didn't find it in citric
until i
read it in the other philosophers later
again i think peter rarelton is one who
uses this and that is that if you're
really asking what people would do if
they're rational and fully informed
you have to make judgments about what is
a rational and fully informed view in
this situation
and that might involve even
the views that we've just been
discussing that if you're a rational you
would know what the objective truth was
and you would want to do it so at that
level the preference view actually seems
to amount to
a different view an objectivist view
that you
would hold where you would have to
actually know what the things that were
good to do
so as i say it had a number of internal
problems even just if you assume the
matter ethic
that i was taking from here originally
but if then
has happened with me you become
convinced that there can be objective
moral truths
this was in some ways opened up the
field to other possible ideas as to what
was intrinsically good
because now you could argue that
something was intrinsically good even
was not
something that people preferred and in
that light i went back to reading
some of the classical utilitarians again
particularly siddwick and his arguments
for why happiness rather than the
satisfaction of desires
is the ultimate value something that is
of intrinsic value
and it did seem to overcome these
problems with preference utilitarianism
that had been troubling me
it certainly had some paradoxes of its
own
some things that it seemed not to handle
as well but
you know after thinking about it again i
decided that it was
more likely than not that a hedonistic
few was the right view
i wouldn't put it stronger than that i
still think preference utilitarianism
has some things to be said for it and
there are also of course
views that say yes happiness is
intrinsically good and suffering is
intrinsically bad but they're not the
only things that are intrinsically good
or bad
things like justice or freedom or
whatever
you know there's various other
candidates that people have put forward
many of them in fact for
being objectively good or bad so there
are also possibilities
when you mention that happiness or
certain sorts of conscious states of
sentient creatures can be seen as
intrinsically good or valuable keeping
in mind sort of
the moral realism that you hold what is
the
metaphysical status of experiences
in the universe given this view is it
that happiness is good based off of
the application of reason in the
rational space of ethics
unpack the ontology of happiness and the
metaphysics here a bit
but of course it doesn't change what
happiness is that's to say that it's of
intrinsic value but that is the
claim that i'm making that the world is
a better place
if it has more happiness in it and less
suffering in it
that's a judgment that i'm making about
the state of the universe
obviously they have to be beings who can
be happy or can be miserable and that
requires a conscious mind
but the judgment that the universe is
better
with more happiness and less suffering
is mind independent i think
let's imagine that there were beings
that could feel pain and pleasure
but could not make any judgments about
anything of value they're like some
non-human animals i guess
it would still be the case that the
universe was better if those non-human
animals
suffered less and had more pleasure
right because it would be sort of a
intrinsic quality or property to the
experience that it be
valuable or just valuable so yeah thanks
so much for your time peter it's really
been
wonderful and informative if people
would like to follow you
or check you out somewhere where can
they go ahead and do that
i have a website which actually i'm in
the process of reconstructing a bit but
it's peter singer.info
there's a wikipedia page they want to
look at things that i'm involved in they
can look at the life you can save dot
org which is the
non-profit organization that i founded
that is recommending
effective charities that people can
donate to that probably gives people a
bit of an idea
those books that i've written that are
discussing these things i've already
mentioned the point of view of the
universe which goes into
the things we've discussed today
probably more thoroughly than anything
else
for people who don't want to read a big
book i've also got oxford university
press's very short introduction series
the book on utilitarianism is again
co-authored by the same co-author as the
point of view of the universe
karagina de lazari radek and myself and
that's just a 100-page
version of some of these arguments we've
been discussing wonderful well
thanks again peter we haven't ever met
in person but hopefully i'll catch you
around the effective altruism
conference track sometime soon okay
thanks so much peter
hey it's post podcast lucas here and
just wanted to chime in with some of my
thoughts and tie this all into ai
thinking for me the most consequential
aspect of
moral thought in this space and moral
philosophy generally is how much
disagreement there is between
people who have thought long and hard
about this issue and what an enormous
part of ai alignment this makes up and
the effects different
moral and meta-ethical views have on
preferred
ai alignment methodology current general
estimates by ai researchers put human
level ai
on the decade the century-long time
scale with about a 50 percent
probability by mid-century with that
obviously increasing over time
and it's quite obvious that moral
philosophy ethics and issues of value
and meaning will not be solved on that
time scale
so if we assume at the worst case
success story where
technical alignment and coordination and
strategy issues will continue
in their standard rather morally messy
way with how we
currently unreflectively deal with
things where moral information isn't
taken very seriously
then i'm really hoping that technical
alignment and coordination succeed well
enough for us to create a very low level
align system
that we were able to pull the brakes on
and work hard on issues of value
ethics and meaning the end towards which
that agi will be aimed
otherwise it seems very clear that given
all this moral uncertainty that is
shared we risk
value drift or catastrophically
unoptimal or even negative futures
turning into peter's views that we
discussed here today
if axioms of morality are accessible
through reason alone
as the axioms of mathematics appear to
be then we ought to consider
the implications here for how we want to
progress with ai systems and ai
alignment more generally
if we take human beings to be agents of
limited or semi-rationality then we
could expect that some of us or some
fraction of us have gained access to
what might potentially be
core axioms of the logical space of
morality
when ai systems are trained on human
data in order to infer and learn human
preferences
given peter's view this can be seen as a
way of learning the moral thinking of
imperfectly rational beings
this or any empirical investigation
given peter's views would not be able to
arrive at
any clear moral truth rather it would
find areas where semi-rational beings
like ourselves
generally tend to converge in this space
this would be useful or potentially
passable
up until agi but if such a system is to
be
fully autonomous and safe then a more
robust form of alignment is necessary
if the agi we create is one day rational
putting aside whatever reason might be
and how it gives
rational creatures access to
self-evident truths and rational spaces
then if agi is a fully rational agent
then it
perhaps would arrive at self-evident
truths of mathematics
and logic and even morality just as
aliens on another planet might if they
are fully rational as is
peter's view if so this would
potentially be evidence
of this view being true and we can also
reflect here that
agi from this point of using reason to
have
insight into the core truths of logical
spaces could reason much better and more
impartially than any human
in order to fully explore and realize
universal truths of morality
at this point we would essentially have
a perfect moral reasoner on our hands
with
access to timeless universal truths now
the question would be
could we trust it and what would ever be
sufficient reasoning or explanation
given to humans by this
moral oracle that would satisfy and
satiate us of our appetites and desires
to know moral truth and to be sure that
we have arrived at moral truth
it's above my pay grade what rationality
or reason actually
is and might be prior to certain logical
and mathematical axioms and how such a
truth-seeking meta-awareness can grasp
these truths as self-evident
or whether the self-evidence of the
truths of mathematics and logic
are programmed into us by evolution
trying and failing
over millions of years but maybe that's
an issue for another time
regardless we're doing philosophy
computer science and poli-sci on a
deadline
so let's keep working on getting it
right
if you enjoyed this podcast please
subscribe
give it a like or share it on your
preferred social media platform
we'll be back again soon with another
episode in the ai alignment series